[Musique]
sourire en coin charlie watts était la
force tranquille des rolling stones
[Musique]
pour moi
ils ne disent que c'est la guerre des
sambre mais moi je pense que ces langues
des stands
à wembley en angleterre charlie watts
était un passionné de jazz qui a appris
seul à jouer de la batterie en 1963 il a
rejoint front line stone's et jusqu'à la
fin il a été derrière cet impôt
inoubliable du groupe
qui
[Musique]
la façon qu'ils jouaient c'était
tellement clean c'est tellement propre
et les trous que ce que ça donnait pour
la musique des stands étaient et c'était
cela commence charlie watts à vannes
swing qui datent d'une autre époque et
que les ja puceau puis c'est une façon
de méthyle latin
réservés charlie watts maintenant
certain équilibre dans la vie
rock'n'roll des rolling stones lui qui a
eu la même conjointe pendant 50 ans
n'avait rien de flamboyant nous dit le
producteur serge grimaux
[Musique]
super sens de l'humour c'était vraiment
une personne qui se promenait en arrière
scène et puis qui impose le par son aura
une espèce de recettes méditez respect
immédiat une personne exceptionnelle
[Musique]
entre deux albums des rolling stones le
doyen du groupe a réalisé en solo des
albums de jazz on l'a d'ailleurs déjà vu
à montréal
malade le musicien avait subi récemment
une opération et ils avaient annoncé
qu'ils ne participeraient pas à la
prochaine tournée de son groupe le jour
de son décès les hommages fusent de
toutes parts entre autres du batteur des
beatles ringo starr le site des rolling
stones a été fermé laissant comme seule
image celle de charlie watts très
souvent c'est parce que pour moi ça va
être la fin dit non je ne sais pas
comment ils vont ils vont continuer à
changer lui
mais on était chanceux de la voie
jusqu'à l'âge de 81 ans
c'est seulement du rock'n roll mais ils
ont été nombreux à aimer le sort unique
de charlie watts sans lui les rolling
stones ne seront plus jamais les mêmes
ici oui fait depuis mai radio canada
montréal
[Musique]
poursuivons avec mike gauthier animateur
radio chroniqueur musical mike gauthier
bonsoir bonsoir deux choses d'abord il
ya déjà que 10 c'est la fin des stands
mais laisse ton deux repartent en
tournée dans quelques semaines et
c'était prévu qu'ils allaient le faire
sans lui alors d'après vous est ce que
c'est la fin des stands quand même
éventuelle mais je dirais que il faut
savoir qu'il ya de ça quelques jours
paris match a écrit que les stones se
prépare une tournée qui pour être
considéré tournée d'adieu pour l'année
prochaine le but de la tournée ce serait
de jouer dans des endroits dans des
monuments historiques comme exemple pour
paris ce serait en bas de la tour eiffel
pour offrir le tour du monde comme ça
pour dire un dernier au revoir à tous
les fans alors j'ai comme l'impression
que nous on a appris aujourd'hui le cas
de charlie wax décédé mais possiblement
dans l'entourage on avait déjà eu des
nouvelles à cet effet pour on s'est dit
bon est-ce qu'on va finalement faire le
chant du cygne pour la prochaine tournée
c'est peut-être ça qu'on avait préparé
mélo celui qui va le remplacer c'est une
personne qui est dans l'entourage de
kikwit shirt depuis des années qui
s'appelle steve jordan c'est un batteur
d'ailleurs quand ils prennent shirts
avaient travaillé dans les laurentides
au studio morin heights pour son premier
album solo jordan était avec lui puis
elle m'a même coréalisé l'album ça fait
que les stands voulais finir cette
tournée l'anophèle d'europe l'année
prochaine j'ai comme l'impression que ça
va faire quoi faire 60 ans j'ai comme
l'impression qu'on va dire au revoir et
merci mais s'intéresse à ce que vous
dites mike gauthier vous dites que ça
freine oeuvres est vrai parce que des
tournées d'adieu un des groupes qui ont
fait 12 ce serait le vrai vraie tournée
d'adieux et la mort de charlie watts et
hop le prélude de tout ça mais
possiblement parce que des stands j'ai
comme l'impression qu'à après 60 ans oui
c'est beau a amassé des millions de
dollars lorsqu'on fait des tournées mais
pourquoi ne pas finir en beauté moi je
trouve que de donner des concerts dans
des endroits qui sont historiques c'est
une très bonne idée ça serait une belle
façon
de dire que c'est terminé l'aventuré des
rolling stones beaucoup de gens qui
disent que le fait que charlie watts
s'en va ça va possiblement peut-être
sensibiliser les autres à tourner la
page sur cette belle grande histoire du
rock n roll on sait pas si le stade
olympique qui considérait comme un lieu
historique
est ce que le coach ce qu'ils
deviendront à toronto
mike gauthier je veux revenir sur le le
style parce qu'on l'a vu dans lequel
bien penaud
le côté jeu pour reprendre l'expression
dans le reportage clean
sociaux comme du pire c'est ce qui est
intéressant il ya créé le petit kit
switchers avec la façon dont il y avait
ces légendaires riffs bon a bâti le son
des stands mais charlie watts également
avec ça la section rythmique avec sa
façon de jouer de la batterie l'a
vraiment aussi permis aux stands d'avoir
leurs propres sont moins de dix chansons
que j'aime beaucoup la même avant d'en
au début des années 60 le avec gallois
peuvent marque la route il y était
différent des autres charlie wax mais
après ça il a dit il ya des riffs qui
l'a développé quasiment lui aussi au
niveau de la batterie dans emotional
rescue c'est intéressant magne sur
l'album cd rw eaks de qui marquait le
retour des citrons en 1989 après des
années de tumulte il était vraiment
intense et illettré il était vraiment en
bon pied il ya vraiment donner une
couleur tu entends une chanson des
rolling stones et tu reconnais tout de
suite grâce à la batterie ou aux riffs
de quitterie chase le reconnaît
immédiatement les rolling stones on va
les écouter toute la nuit mike gauthier
oui l'animateur radio chroniqueur
musical merci beaucoup nous en parler